in the last video i talked about how
bitcoin transactions are really
incorporated into a global and a
publicly accessible ledger of sorts that
we call the transaction blockchain and
this work is actually carried out by
nodes
in the bitcoin network that are known as
bitcoin miners and as a reward for all
that effort especially since some of the
uh
computational heavy lifting is done by
these bitcoin miners they're basically
awarded a
certain number of bitcoins for their
efforts and this happens by the miners
effectively constructing what's called a
coin based transaction and then
basically assigning themselves bitcoins
within that transaction so in a sense
then and this is kind of intriguing
bitcoins are effectively generated
almost out of thin air during this
process and of course if you see
something like that that might raise in
your mind the question of whether uh
there is ever an upper limit to the the
bitcoin money supply and fortunately the
answer or maybe not so fortunately
depending on your viewpoint the answer
to that question is actually yes and the
bitcoin system is actually designed so
that there can be at most at most 21
million bitcoins ever generated okay so
that's the maximum number of bitcoins
ever that can ever come up in the system
uh beyond that point no more new
bitcoins will ever be accepted or
generated or allowed to be generated and
so as a result
nodes
at that point or from that point onward
once 21 million bitcoins have been
generated nodes will no longer get a
reward for augmenting the transaction
blockchain okay these bitcoin miners who
do all this effort are not going to get
a guaranteed award for doing that effort
and keep in mind that because every
transaction in the bitcoin system is
public and the nodes in the system
actually know
how many coins have been generated it's
possible to really enforce these limits
on the total number of bitcoins created
now there are actually two points i want
to make regarding this particular limit
so first of all
even after it's reached you know we're
still going to need nodes to do what
bitcoin mining nodes do today so that
involves things like incorporating
transactions into transaction blocks and
incorporating these transaction blocks
into
transaction block chains and so on and
so forth
but if you think about it for a moment
once the 21 million coin limit is
reached these nodes don't get that
automatic reward
of bitcoins for performing this extra
effort and now you might be wondering
well what incentive is there for these
nodes
to engage in this additional effort i
mean why are they doing this sort of
thing if they're not going to get
bitcoins as a guarantee for for doing
that work and really at this point um
the hope is that uh when we reach the 21
million bitcoin limiter as we get closer
and closer to it that actually
transaction fees will play a more
prominent role in a node's decision to
be a bitcoin
mining node and
in particular
the idea here is that we hope the
transaction fees will be
enough of an incentive and more and more
people well
in general i think hopefully by this
point we'll be using bitcoin and so as a
result um i think there is
an expectation or it's not unreasonable
to think that as more and more people
use bitcoins
there will be more and more transactions
and as a result more and more
opportunity to make money off of
transaction fees and it turns out that
in the context of bitcoin mining
a lot of the heavy lifting is in this
proof-of-work piece not in being able to
incorporate all these transactions into
a transaction block
so even if there's a lot of transactions
in the transaction block it's not that
much more effort for the the miners to
really incorporate those extra
transactions but if they're getting if
they're getting all these extra
transaction fees then that might be a
good incentive for them
okay it's also worth noting that
transaction fees are actually set
by the payer in bitcoin
okay the payer then is going to have the
onus of
setting the
fee appropriately so that the nodes
in the bitcoin network are
incentivized to add that payers
transactions to their transaction blocks
all right
so hopefully that makes some sense uh
the second point i want to make
regarding this this limit of 21 million
bitcoins is that really bitcoin does
allow
for fractional coins and i haven't
really talked much about that in this
video since i've really
kind of implicitly talked only about the
idea of coins being these whole entities
like alice transferring 10 coins to bob
or 25 points to bob and so on
but it turns out you can actually have
coins that are fractional
okay and in fact the smallest possible
unit
in bitcoin it's a very small number it's
zero 0.000001
bitcoins
okay and this is one
100 millionth of a bitcoin and this
actually used this unit by the way just
as an fyi is known
as a satoshi
and this name actually comes from the
name satoshi nakamoto
and satoshi nakamoto is the the
pseudonym
of the inventor of bitcoin nobody
actually is sure that there is somebody
actually named satoshi nakamoto but as
far as anybody can tell the only person
who's ever taken credit for the
invention of bitcoin is this the satoshi
nakamoto name and and
it's unlikely there's actually a person
behind that name but it's more likely
maybe some type of a group or something
of that nature
okay now aside from that there are
actually a couple of other additional
controls that i want to mention
uh that are built into bitcoin for
keeping the growth of that money supply
in check
so first of all
the reward provided to bitcoin miners
actually decreases over time
okay
and if you if you were aware when
bitcoin began which was around uh
january of 2009
at that time the reward for a bitcoin
miner
to do their effort was 50 bitcoins okay
now the way that the reward structure is
set up is that every 210 000 blocks so
when you get to a 210 000 block period
every time 210 000 new blocks are
generated the reward size actually gets
cut
uh in half okay
and so what that means is that um once
two hundred ten thousand blocks are
generated the word goes from 50 bitcoins
to 25 bitcoins from 25 to 12 and a half
and so on and so forth
all right now it does take approximately
approximately four years uh to generate
210 000 blocks and i'll talk a little
bit later about where this four years
numbers come from
but as of right now i'm recording this
video it's may 2013
the current reward is actually no longer
50 bitcoins the current reward now is is
actually 25
uh bitcoins per per mining operation and
it's gonna go down in half in
approximately four years and
that's just going to keep happening
until the estimate is around the year
around the year
two thousand one hundred and forties in
the year twenty one forty were
we will expect that the entire
um
bitcoin supply will have been generated
okay so we're not gonna it's unlikely
we'll be generating bitcoins after 2140
uh 2140 is the point at which all
bitcoins
all bitcoins will have been generated
okay
now
the last way to limit the generation of
bitcoins is to actually calibrate the
difficulty of solving that proof of work
protocol at a global level okay and so i
also want to point out that another
functionality that bitcoin has built
into it is that
for every
blocks that are generated the network
basically estimates the time that it
took to generate those blocks it looks
at you know how long did it take to join
the first of these blocks and how long
it would take to generate the last of
these blocks and it measures uh that
amount of time
now if that amount of time is
uh
let's say it's um i don't know let's say
it's something that's significantly um
let's say it's significantly
uh bigger than two weeks okay so if it's
significantly bigger than two weeks then
the proof-of-work protocol will be
simplified okay we're going to calibrate
it so that it's easier to generate
blocks
on the flip side let's say it took a lot
less than two weeks to
generate these 2016 blocks in that case
the proof of work will be again
calibrated to be made more difficult
okay and the goal is that we want
it to be the case that of 2016 blocks we
want it to be the case that it takes
about two weeks
to generate these blocks about 14 days
to generate 2016 blocks
okay
and to get a better sense for why that
number
is the way it is you could see that
let's say
let's say it takes about uh
two weeks to generate uh 2016 blocks uh
what that actually will imply is that it
takes about 10 minutes before the proof
of work is actually solved and a new
transaction
is
a new transaction block rather is folded
into the overall transaction blockchain
and you can actually work out that if
you if you
if it took 10 minutes to to validate or
to come up with one new block in the
system at a global level and you
multiply that by by obviously uh by six
to get the number of blocks generated
per hour so you get six blocks per hour
or really six new proofs of work per
hour which in turn would lead to six new
transaction blocks per hour you multiply
that by 24
hours per day
and then you multiply that by 14 days
and you'll actually find that when you
when you multiply these things together
you will get the number
okay and so you can you can get a sense
of where this number comes from and i
want to make one last final clarifying
remark regarding this this proof of work
um since
solving the proof of work actually
requires
a bitcoin mining node to come up with
the proof string which it currently does
through some type of exhaustive search
as you increase the number of bitcoin
mining nodes on the network then really
all else being equal the proof of work
will be solved faster
okay and when i i don't mean faster for
a particular lord i mean faster at the
level of the entire network in other
words um it'll take less time before at
least one node comes up with the
solution because these nodes are all
working on that same problem
concurrently and actually on that node i
do also want to mention quickly uh maybe
a more subtle point which is that
even though the different bitcoin mining
nodes are all validating
either the exact same
uh set of transactions or maybe a
largely overlapping set of transactions
they actually are all solving
entirely different proof-of-work
protocols when they're doing this sort
of thing and the reason for that is that
each node remember inserts its own coin
base or generational transaction into
the block that it's working on to award
itself points
okay and this generational or coinbase
transaction is actually unique to each
node so as a result the challenge string
for which let's say each bitcoin mining
node is seeking a corresponding proof of
work well that challenge student will be
different for each bitcoin
you know each bitcoin mining node rather
and so essentially what you have is that
because you have a cryptographic hash
function that's being used in the
process
just this one difference the fact that
just this one piece is different that
actually completely randomizes
the proof of work problem that results
and that makes it likely that across the
entire network
the solutions are likely to be widely
distributed and we can expect that if we
have enough nodes one node will come up
with a solution uh in about 10 minutes
okay at least one of the nodes will they
won't all do it but at least one will
and once one node comes up with a
solution everyone else can kind of
proceed from that point onward with the
new chain
so as you can see the bitcoin protocol
you know takes
a number of measures it implements a
number of mechanisms to both limit the
total number of bitcoins as well as the
rate at which these bitcoins are
ultimately generated